I told you a week or two ago that an
indictment was allegedly imminent
against former Trump campaign manager
Paul Manafort specifically for his
involvement in the Trump Russia scandal
we now have a Democratic senator not
just any Democratic senator actually but
one who would know about this because
he's on the Senate Judiciary Committee
Connecticut Democrat Richard Blumenthal
says he is 99% sure that indictments are
coming for both Paul Manafort Trump's
former campaign manager and chairman and
for Michael Flynn Trump's former
national security adviser Blumenthal
says that criminal charges he believes
our ninety-nine percent likely against
both Manafort
and Flynn in the Trump Russia scandal
he said that mana fort and Flynn are the
most prominent but that there well may
be others who also will face criminal
charges CNN's Manu Raju who has really
done pretty good reporting on this story
all along he tweeted yesterday Roger
stone who has been a guest on this
program before by the way Roger stone
says man afford attorneys have told his
attorneys that mana fort expects to be
indicted soon I want to talk about
something with you
here in a slightly different way I've
talked about the importance of the
midterm elections to stop the total
control by Republicans of the House
Senate and White House I've talked about
the importance of the 2018 election sort
of as a positioning election for 2020
I've talked about it as an opportunity
to put a halt to the possibility of
making our health care system even worse
through the passage of the types of
proposals that fortunately so far have
failed by Republicans all the
legislative concerns the Trump Russia
story is actually another situation that
may well be impacted by the 2018
midterms I've said it before I'll say it
again
Trump Russia could go on for a long time
and I previously gave you the timeline
of Watergate and Richard Nixon and
there's every indication that it could
be a very long time even from the first
indictment it could be years until the
entire Trump Russia scandal is resolved
so the 2018 midterms could actually have
a major impact on what
what happens with Trump Russia because
depending on whether it's Democrats or
Republicans that control the house from
2018 to 2020 depending on whether it's
Democrats or Republicans that control
the house of the Senate rather between
2018 and 2020 that could have a major
impact on the future of the Trump Russia
investigation because a
republican-controlled house might react
to what is the eventual report from
special prosecutor Robert Moeller very
differently than a democratically
controlled house same thing with the
Senate so we need to be thinking about
2018
not only because midterms are
opportunities for the opposition party
to make gains not only because we need
to do everything we can to prevent
Donald Trump's harebrained ideas from
becoming reality but also because it
could impact whether we eventually
actually see justice in the Trump Russia
investigation and then along these lines
I find it truly stunning that we have a
sitting active President of the United
States whose former campaign Chairman is
arguably about to be indicted whose
former national security adviser is also
facing criminal indictment and there are
people who either number one don't think
this is a big deal number two think it's
fake news or number three don't even
know about it
because the Trump Russia scandal is
barely being mentioned as anything other
than a left-wing conspiracy theory on
right-wing media a lot of people don't
even know what's going on how do you
feel though about these representatives
like Richard Blumenthal and Mark Warner
going out there and giving updates on
the investigation I just think that the
Republican charge is that this is all a
witch-hunt and it's all about political
posturing and they kind of validated I
would just like to see you know the
investigation run its course and the
truth come out as it may yeah that's a
different question than whether we
believe dick Blumenthal right I don't
think dick Blumenthal would say that
there's a 99 percent chance of
indictment if he doesn't think that
there is and if it's not backed by
something that he's seen but there's a
fair question there which is maybe
everybody should let just let the entire
thing run its course and if the
indictments actually do happen then
you've kind of let the air out of the
balloon I mean this should be treated as
such a big breaking news story and yet
we've already got hints that's gonna
happen anyway I think it still will be a
major breaking news story because a
former national security adviser being
indicted is still going to be big but
it's a fair point it's a fair point and
and to sort of illuminate this point a
little bit
more I want to put up on the screen a
slide from one of my lectures in the
class I'm teaching at Boston College
about what I'm calling informational
incongruity and this is what we're
seeing when it comes to Trump Russia you
can have an issue where everybody is
sort of aware of the issue and
understands that the issue is a big deal
but they differ on opinions right so
like most people understand abortion has
been a big political issue there is
someone who might think abortion should
be legal and safe versus someone who
thinks abortion should be illegal but
everybody agrees this is an issue and
it's an important issue then layer two
would be an issue where there is
disagreement as to the importance right
so you might have one side which says
gay marriage is a really important issue
and another side that says the
importance of gay marriage as a
political debate is overblown meaning we
don't even really think that gay
marriage is an issue that should be
discussed layer three of informational
incongruity which is a total lack of
awareness of the topics that others find
important right so I have an example
here hypothetical about North Korea but
we are actually seeing such
informational incongruity on Trump
Russia that lots of people barely
understand the scope of what is going on
and it makes it very difficult to
actually have conversations with others
when that's the case so just just
something to think about in total
informational incongruity going on here